all right so as most of you probably
noticed while i was gone
donald trump wasn't reinstated joe biden
is still the president mike lindell was
wrong
uh q you know whatever z why they they
were all wrong axe okay oh you guys get
it trump is not going to be reinstated
um the department of homeland security
is now actually increasingly worried
about the demands for violence they're
starting to see from trumpist circles
if donald trump is not reinstated now of
course you and i know trump is not going
to be reinstated and so that's very very
concerning there's a good rolling stone
article which we're going to look at by
peter wade
called die hard trump supporters
increasingly demand violence if he isn't
reinstated homeland security warns
the department of homeland security
issued a warning believers in the false
conspiracy theory that trump will be
reinstated have increased their calls
for violence if the former president
isn't back in the white house soon
some conspiracy theories associated with
reinstating former president trump have
included calls for violence if desired
outcomes are not realized the dhs
bulletin obtained by abc news said the
bulletin went on to say that the recent
increase in public visibility of liars
like the my pillow guy mike lindell
by the way check out his interview with
me from a couple weeks ago
is the reason for the uptick in violent
online chatter
lindell continues to relentlessly push
the big lie that the election was stolen
going so far as to say that he expects
the supreme court to unanimously rule in
favor of reinstating trump as president
in august that's a delusional belief
over the last few days what has occurred
is there's been much more public
visibility meaning the discussions and
these theories have migrated away from
being contained within
the conspiracy extremist online
communities to where they're being the
topic of discussion on web forums or
more public web forums even within the
sort of media ecosystem that's according
to a senior dhs official
the drunk on trump crowd has been
triggered so much that homeland security
says they're concerned about the calls
for violence increasing further we have
been concerned about the exact same
thing
going on to say the does this bulletin
as public visibility of the narratives
increases we're concerned about more
calls to violence past circumstances
have illustrated that calls for violence
could expand rapidly in the public
domain
and may be occurring outside of publicly
available channels as such lone
offenders and small groups of
individuals could mobilize to violence
with little to no warning
the dhs added although they do not have
specifics of an imminent threat their
reporting indicates the timing for these
activities may occur during august
although we lack information on specific
plots or planned actions so there's a
few different things here number one
donald trump is going back to the
rallies this saturday this saturday
in fact
uh
i'm debating i'll tell you it's like
this this stuff is so base but i'll tell
you so there's trump's doing a rally in
alabama this saturday uh 8 p.m east 7
p.m central i'll i'll be streaming it
there are some who believe that at this
rally donald trump is going to call
for another insurrection and that all
hell is going to break loose that's one
hypothesis
the other
idea that's been floated
is that at the rally saturday
trump will be reinstated that's the the
it'll be in alabama because it's a good
southern state i guess who the hell
knows and trump will be reinstated on
saturday and there are
fears
that when he is obviously not reinstated
saturday um that some of the followers
will will take the violence um
immediately
i don't know what the hell is going on
so that's one piece of it and that's
part of the relevance of this this
particular week secondly
how low brow is it to have trump as a
hero
like what it you know it's this is very
coarse right it's not this is not deep
politics but
the bizarre hair and the strange tan and
the idiocy he doesn't know anything
about history or economics or politics
hasn't read a book in his adult life
he's a billionaire but he can't even
even get suits that look even reasonably
okay
like he's just an embarrassing mess of a
person
and you really have to understand cults
to understand what's going on it's it's
the jim jones stuff i go back to the
people's temple
um
uh road to jonestown check out jeff
guinn's book it's a fantastic it's
instructive history really about how
these cult leader types end up with the
followers that they have so
dhs is worried
we've been worried and let's hope that
nothing like this happens this weekend
one of our sponsors is steady md primary
care the easier and more affordable way
to do primary care and they're giving
you 50 off because you are in my
audience you just answer a few questions
steadymd will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs you'll have a one-hour
virtual appointment and start a
meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on your doctor will
be available to you by text phone and
video chat it's not some random doctor
on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients you get the attention
you deserve and they can help you with
anything your primary care doc normally
would it's very cool how it works you
don't need insurance
it's just 99 bucks a month no other fees
or co-pays for visits take the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get 50 off your first
month when you go to steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video